all right we're at the desk with a total
Dreamboat Darcy Cardin and it's time for
two drinks
[Music]
see we've got a few categories today and
you're gonna give us three spicy facts
and we have to figure out and guess
which is alive and if we're right then
you have to give us some more scoop ooh
I like that and if we're wrong Russ and
I have to share a spicy true fact about
ourselves oh
yeah it sounds like win-win I know all
right here we go round one two truths
and a lie about your career okay I was
voted the actress with hottest on-screen
kiss roster with a list of Justin Long
maniacinto Kristen Bell Abby Jacobson
Lenny Kravitz we're gonna say that
sounds terrorist okay the most Jennifer
Coolidge thing that Jennifer Coolidge
did was she tried to take a photo using
the iTunes app of her phone if that
sounds true
my first job was a swim teacher I
I mean you do look sporty thank you the
outfit is nautical
okay we're torn on this one but we're
gonna say skeptical okay okay okay all
right the LIE is that I was voters voted
the actors with the hottestines oh but
this is a tricky one but you've been
with kids
everyone I had just named but no one's
given me a damn award for it oh now
that's a shame they should thank you and
we can do that right now
[Applause]
she is you know she has like this
Persona she is really smart and cool and
with it and like ahead of the joke but
she's just really bad at like technology
yeah so I watched her like try to take a
picture of the Moon and she kept like
trying to she was like swiping in and
out of her iTunes okay so that is true
yeah all right we gotta get Jennifer
Coolidge
[Applause]
that's happened um and I was a swim
teacher you were a student
okay so what do we do fight
now we throw down well we got it wrong
we have to share a spicy true fact okay
go what's a spicy true fact about you I
think I've told this story before but
one time I had had some drinks and uh I
walked into a bar and my fellow co-star
Hugh Grant was in there and for whatever
reason I just grabbed him and started
kissing him like full on kissing
yes did he did he kiss that I will I
will do Hue okay
[Laughter]
and then I just was like bye
that's so hard
[Applause]
alcohol what about you Rossi I think I
need to drink more is what I need to do
and kiss you grant yeah that sounds fun
um do I have a like a spicy one oh I
mean like um I was dating Amy or um
Ortega in seventh grade and I broke up
her today Amy Taylor it was a big yeah
and then we we kissed at Aladdin yeah
that was a big one wow we were spray
painted in an ex-boyfriend's car in the
heat of anger
[Laughter]
really okay
you're giving these away for free what
no I'm skeptical of this one
round two yeah shall we yes okay I first
initially attracted my husband with a
very loud burp well I hope that's true
me too okay
my personal slash aspirational flirting
style is most like my character Greta
gill from League of Their Own okay I'm
leaning yeah because also I know your
character and how you play her in that
but maybe okay yeah what's the third one
my favorite genre is romantic comedy I
think the middle one about your
character on League of Their Own is the
is the LIE what do you think yeah
because you're kind of like tough and
like cool and hard to get in League of
Their Own as far as I like I yeah but in
real life are you okay what's the LIE
the LIE is that my favorite genre is
romantic comedy
this
is a little bit again of a of a
trickster because when a romantic comedy
is good it is like one of my favorite
movies is a Wedding Singer by The
Wedding Singer
[Applause]
not to shotgun wedding it but Josh and
JLo have such great chemistry like the
chemistry between the two leads is what
it's all about for me and I agree you're
the queen of chemistry thank you yeah
yeah
[Applause]
life we have a very platonic
relationship we always have we always
will like that but I'm so in love with
who he is as a human being and his
talent and his heart and Humanity that
it's easy to pretend I'm in love with
him I'm that way I feel like the same
would be said about you because all of
your co-stars have gugu Gaga eyes for
you you it's just like you just when
you're watching romantic comedy and
you're like they don't even like each
other that's then I want to turn it off
yeah but it's like a little asexual to
it it's really weird yeah please say but
you're right Josh and JLo are both so
hot how could they not be attracted to
it yeah all right well thank you Darcy
Cardin don't forget to stream shotgun
wedding
time
[Music]